on a vu dans un épisode précédent que la
plupart des publications scientifiques
sont probablement erronée et ça ça peut
paraître être un constat très sévère
pire encore ces deux publications
suggère que le problème est d'autant
plus grave que le journal de publication
et prestigieux ce qui se justifie
notamment par le biais de publications
dont on a parlé dans un épisode
précédent
voilà qui semble très embarrassant la
science ne consiste-t-elle pas justement
à publier des choses vraies avant
d'aller plus loin il semble crucial de
distinguer deux aspects très distincts
des sciences à savoir d'un côté les
sciences s'établit et de l'autre les
avancées scientifiques
alors bien entendu la frontière entre
deux temps fait assez flou il s'agit
même beaucoup plus d'un continuum qu une
démarcation évidente
néanmoins il est crucial de garder en
tête que ce sont là deux choses très
différentes les sciences et habib celles
qui sont enseignées vulgariser sur
youtube est promue en tant que consensus
scientifique
ce sont les sciences qui se doivent
d'être le plus proche d'une forme de
vérité ou du moins qui se doivent d'être
un corpus crédible pour décrire le monde
va effectuer des prédictions les
avancées scientifiques
al'inverse appartiennent davantage au
chant de l'exploration et de l'inconnu
particulier le rôle du chercheur n'est
absolument pas de répéter des vérités
connues
son rôle est d'enquêter sur ce qui ne
connaît pas comme le dirait je ne sais
pas qui si un ingénieur c'est ce qu'il
fait il doit arrêter de le faire et si
un chercheur c'est ce qu'il fait il doit
arrêter de le faire et bien sûr quand on
ne sait pas ce qu'on fait on risque très
fort de faire des erreurs
malheureusement dans nos sociétés on a
tendance à stigmatiser ces erreurs y
compris quand il s'agit d'erreurs qu'on
aura fait nous mêmes et bien aujourd'hui
je vais défendre une idée qui peut
paraître assez loufoque
je vais défendre l'idée selon laquelle
si les publications scientifiques
n'était pas plein d'erreurs c'est que
quelque chose en sciences se passera en
fait très très mal
bon en fait ce que je vais défendre est
bien plus subtil que ça mais bon un peu
depuis ta clique pour avoir votre
attention ça ne fait pas de mal
enfin si ça fait un peu de mal mais vous
allez voir le jeu en vaut la chandelle
pour commencer laissez moi vous parler
de cette excellente vidéo de veritas
yonne derek l'auteur de la chaîne à une
règle en tête et il demande à différents
passant de deviner cette règle pour
deviner cette règle les interviewés
peuvent proposer des suites de nombres
et derek répond alors si les suites
proposées suivre ou non la règle que
derek a en tête
par exemple pour commencer derek affirme
que la suite de 4,8 suit la règle
les interviews et propose alors 16 32 64
ce à quoi derek répond oui c'est sûr ma
règle puis 3 6 12 ce à quoi derek répond
à nouveau oui ça suma règle cependant
quand les interviews et affirme abbaoui
du coup la règle est une multiplication
par 2 derek répond non les interviewés
sont alors perplexe il propose ensuite
10 20 40 ou cinq dix vingt ou encore 100
200 400 là encore derek répond oui ce
qui laisse les interviews et sans voix
que se passe-t-il
quelle est la règle de derek mais
surtout que devrait alors faire les
interviews et est ce que je fais quelque
chose de mal demande un des interviews
et est ce que vous voyez ce que les
interviews et font de mal n'hésitez pas
à mettre pause pour y réfléchir
[Musique]
le problème c'est que les interviews se
sont placés dans une zone de confort où
j'étais persuadé d'avoir raison
cependant pour apprendre pour progresser
dans nos connaissances il faut justement
s'extraire de notre zone de confort est
allé explorer d'inconnus l'un des
interviews et propose alors de 4,7 et
derek répond alors oui inc the sting
oui parce que enfin on a une réponse
dont on est surpris
or comme on l'a vu il faut être surpris
pour apprendre
comme le dit le théorème bayésiens de
l'absence de surprise si une donnée est
entièrement prévisible alors la
conclusion doit être égale aux préjugés
en particulier n'aura rien appris pour
la petite histoire une amie m'a dit un
jour investing #owni populo pinion que
j'ai donnée sans aucun argument et j'ai
trouvé sa niche hosting qu'elle les
trouvait ça une chose thing hashtag meta
de métal et d'ailleurs pour le coût en
terme de la taille des bateaux mieux
j'ai beaucoup appris à ce moment-là
répondre investing in #owni populaire
opinion c'est vraiment une réponse pour
le coup une fausseté
et ces extraits illustre
particulièrement bien ces moments où il
se passe quelque chose
interesting oui il a eu peu de temps
après grâce à des réponses investing de
derek les interviews et finir par
trouver la règle de derek mais je vais
éviter de vous la spolier et je vais
simplement recommandé d'aller voir la
vidéo de derek si possible après avoir
fini de regarder la vidéo que vous êtes
en train de regarder ce que j'espère
vous avoir montré avec l'exemple de
derek c'est surtout que ce qui a le plus
de valeur en tout cas dans le contexte
de l'avancement de l'état des
connaissances ce n'est pas la vérité de
ce qu'on découvre ce sont plutôt les
découvertes de données outch hosting
c'est ce qui explique merveilleusement
isaac asimov dont l'une de mes citations
préférées en sciences la phrase la plus
excitante que l'on peut entendre celle
qui annonce de nouvelles découvertes ce
n'est pas eurêka mais c'est drôle c'est
souvent la surprise de données
intrigante ou d'un argument inattendue
qui non seulement fait vibrer les
chercheurs mais aussi et surtout qui
fait avancer
l'assurance et ça ça s'explique
particulièrement bien en termes de
curseur de turing en effet surtout pour
un bayésiens mais aussi pour nous autres
humains aux facultés cognitives limiter
ce curseur n'est pas quelque chose qu'il
faut placer là où il faut il s'agit
davantage d'un curseur qui se trouve
déjà sur la droite de tueries et qu'il
faut ensuite faire glisser le long de
cette droite il faut faire danser ce
curseur et non pas le planter à coups de
marteau piqueur or la danse de ce
curseur n'est pas rythmés par des
vérités dogmatiquement communiqué elle
plus tôt qu'annoncé par la découverte de
données surprenantes en particulier dès
lors l'avancement des sciences se
mesurera davantage dans la faculté à
faire danser adéquatement ce curseur y
compris lorsque malgré un déplacement en
direction d'une théorie t le curseur
n'est pas encore nettement suffisamment
en faveur de cette théorie t pour
affirmer que la théorie t est
probablement vrai autrement dit dans une
optique d'avancées scientifiques il
semble préférable de mesurer la
pertinence d'une publication
scientifique par sa capacité à déplacer
des curseurs de crédence plutôt que par
la probabilité
que la conclusion suggérée par les
données de l'article soit valide
1 quand on parle de surprise il faut
tout de même faire gaffe à la robustesse
de la surprise en effet un résultat peut
paraître surprenant sur le moment avant
que l'on trouve des explications à cette
surprise autre que la remise en question
de nos crédence ce fut le cas notamment
lors de la découverte des neutrinos plus
rapides que la lumière
en fait pour qu'un résultat soit
vraiment surprenant il se doit d'être
robuste autrement dit il doit être un
probable que si on refait l'expérience
ou l'observation on obtienne des données
radicalement différente en particulier
si une donnée largement être une simple
fluctuation statistiques ou un simple
bien expérimental et si elle a subi un
important biais de sélection qui l'a
mise en valeur alors elle ne sera
probablement pas robuste c'est ce manque
de robustesse qui la rend fait peu
surprenante
bref autant ce n'est peut-être pas si
grave que la conclusion suggérée par les
données d'un article demeure peu
crédible autant c'est très dérangeant si
la donnée est présenté comme étant plus
robuste qu'elle ne l'est vraiment en
termes bayésiens il semble donc
judicieux de prioriser la communication
et la diffusion de données empiriques ou
d'arguments qui déplace fortement les
curseurs de turing y compris sous la
direction de ses déplacement du curseur
ne justifie pas la validité de la
théorie qui gagne ainsi de la crédence
ceci étant dit à des placements égaux
tous les déplacements de curseur ne
semble toutefois pas se valoir par
exemple un déplacement majeur du curseur
de crédence sur l'âge d'un arbre
arbitraire du campus de le pfl ne semble
pas aussi important un communiqué qu'un
déplacement major du curseur de crédence
sur dix ont le potentiel de la
reforestation pour combattre le
changement climatique
or l'attention des chercheurs est limité
tout comme leurs sources de financement
dans ce contexte il semble important de
réfléchir à la priorisation des
publications et des recherches
scientifiques les données de certaines
recherches semblent plus importantes à
diffuser que d'autres même si elles ont
des rapports de surprises inférieur
particulier par exemple toutes les
recherches qui portent sur la sécurité
des systèmes complexes et leurs
bienfaits sur nos sociétés et notre
environnement pourrait avoir plus de
valeur
il pourrait ainsi être judicieux de
davantage publié les résultats de telles
recherches et de davantage financer la
recherche dans ces domaines vous renvoie
notamment vers cet article préoccupant
de négoce trône cette question de prix
réalisation de la recherche pourrait
d'ailleurs être une cause d'altruisme
efficace encore beaucoup trop négligée
aujourd'hui d'autant que cette réflexion
est loin d'être aussi évidente
nous avons parce qu'il existe souvent
des manières très indirecte de
contribuer à des causes majeures comme
par exemple mieux comprendre les enjeux
du numérique pour mieux combattre les
problèmes environnementaux en fait
comprendre qu'elle recherche prioriser
est tout un champ de recherche à
lui-même qu'il est par exemple celui sur
lequel travaille l'organisation et
tisanes hours de façon un peu ironique
il semble que la recherche sûre qu'elle
recherche prioriser serait peut être
elle même a davantage prioriser h times
et admettons
bref si j'aurais
au niveau de la recherche scientifique
il semble qu'il serait ainsi préférable
de prioriser la publication de résultats
associés à d'importants rapports de
surprise c'est à dire des déplacements
importants et justifier de nos curseur
de crédence surtout quand il s'agit de
curseur de crédence important à bien
ajustés dans le petit disons du
bien-être de l'humanité
et ce même si par conséquent ces
publications suggéreront l'augmentation
de la crédence de théories qui malgré
ses publications demeureront peu
crédible en fait ce qui est peut être
plus important encore c'est de
distinguer les recherches qui vise à
déplacer le curseur de crédence des
bilans sur l'état de connaissance des
scientifiques qui elle cherche à décrire
par exemple consensus scientifique ou
plus précisément là où se situe et
différents curseurs de crédence des
scientifiques ou 10 en termes bayésiens
il semble crucial de distinguer les
rapports de surprise de nos crédence
volaille est parfaitement résumée par le
proverbe bayésiens qui dit que la
vraisemblance des données n'est pas la
crédence de la théorie la nar fois on a
parlé du sophisme de la logique et
notamment du fait que l'application de
la logique à la science de manière
directe poser en fait d'énormes
problèmes et monsieur fille fait
remarquer que c'est une remarque que de
nombreux logiciels ont fait depuis bien
longtemps et en effet le bail à nice mme
et très près dominant notamment chez les
philosophes des sciences et en
épistémologie et ça c'est super chouette
mais malheureusement de mon expérience
il ya quand même beaucoup encore de
scientifiques et en particulier de
mathématiciens qui ont beaucoup de mal à
s'extraire de la logique et qui pensent
encore que la bonne façon de penser
c'est en s'appuyant sur la logique
uniquement et qui ont typiquement
pleinement accepté la contra posée et
les clans centre là contre a posé son
implication en particulier ça a
longtemps été mon cas c'est à dire que
si j'avais pas eu ces réflexions sur le
bannissement cours des trois dernières
années
vous prenez le lait de 2016 qui était
docteur en mathématiques et qui
travaillait au mythique avait l'air
travaillant tout ça est bien seul et de
2016 ou 2015 plutôt penser absolument
que la contra posait était une vérité
fondamentale
et que c'était un truc qu'il fallait
absolument enseigne telle qu'elle est en
plus en l'enseignant tel quel à de
nombreux étudiants et bien il a mené ses
nombreux étudiants à penser que une
implication quasiment vrai impliquer la
quasi vérité de sa contrat poser en
particulier sur ce que je veux que vous
reteniez de la vidéo précédente c'est
que bien pensé c'est avant tout très
très très compliqué et qu' il faut
absolument chercher à raisonner de façon
probabiliste pour éviter des erreurs de
raisonnement qui pourraient surgir de
d'analogie ou de logique mal appliqué à
différents endroits
ceci étant dit j'ai insiste également
sur le fait que tu apprends des lycéens
tous les modèles sont faux ou certains
sont utiles donc ce n'est pas parce que
une communauté travaille avec
l'hypothèse erronée que les conclusions
de cette communauté ne sont pas
crédibles et en particulier en fait très
probablement ils vont néanmoins arriver
à des conclusions beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus crédible que les
conclusions auxquelles on arriverait si
on utilisait uniquement nos intuitions
et en particulier et énormément de
modèles prédictifs qui s'appuie sur de
la logique pour faire ses prédictions et
pourvu qu'ils n'utilisent pas trop là
contre imposé à mauvais escient
ils seront probablement beaucoup
beaucoup plus crédible que nos
intuitions paradoxe lui mentionne le
paradoxe de bord à yoko ono graphique
est un merveilleux au pardoxe en théorie
des probabilités qui a à voir avec le
fait que techniquement il est possible
de définir des probabilités
conditionnelles associés à des
conditions qui ont fait une probabilité
0 d'arrivée où par exemple s'il veut
prendre une sphère et si je vous dis que
je prends au hasard un point sur cette
affaire et qui se trouve sur un grand
cercle en particulier alors on envie de
dire qu'il y a une façon de parler de la
probabilité conditionnelle de la
position de ce point sur la sphère
sachant qu'ils se trouvent sur un camp
cercle mais du coup on peut se demander
quelle est cette loi de probité
conditionnelle dans quelle zone sur le
cercle
ce point le plus de chance de se trouver
et ce qui est bizarre c'est qu'on a une
probabilité conditionnel donc
conditionnée par le fait que l'on sait
que le point et sur le grand cercle en
question or la probabilité d'avoir un
point tirer au hasard sur la sphère qui
se trouve sur le grand cercle en
question est égal à zéro et en fait on
n'est pas du tout au bout de nous ennuie
puisque on a envie de dire intuitivement
que ce point n importe où sur le cercle
grands cercles en question et que du
coup la probabilité est uniforme sur ce
grand cercle
mais en fait c'est plus compliqué que ça
à cause du paradoxe de bourrel
kolmogorov montre que suivant la manne
hier dont on identifie l'ensemble des
points qui se rapproche de ce grand
serre en particulier si l'on prend un
espèce dano autour de la sphère où si on
prend deux demi lune il y en a marre
tire des conclusions différentes sur la
loi de probabilités conditionnelles en
question donc les paradoxes de brighton
degroof vous invite à aller voir la page
wikipédia qui est pas très bien expliqué
malheureusement non peut-être que je
ferais comme une vidéo sur ce sujet pour
clarifier tout ça alors qu'ils avaient
vu cette vidéo et que vous aurez trouvé
cela il faut souvent parce que ça aura
déplacé certains curseur de ces danses
important à bouger je vais faire cette
personne parmi nous vous avez cette
vidéo pensez à la ligue avec ans qu'elle
a partagés quant à vous abonner pour
s'ancrer sur l'épisode morceau qui doit
perdre et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois i'm the view nous avons
tout fait cette semaine son éditeur il
existe un jeu de cartes que j'adore il
s'appelle et le registre il est très
simple mais qu'il apprécie en
particulier que le but du jeu c'est de
découvrir les règles du jeu